[Music]
[Applause]
alright alright
did anybody prove that TSA is actually
doing a good job we don't know who to
write to they're like you know they're
Hall monitors right like we get that
right they have no real jurisdiction at
all there was a segment I saw in the
news they said that more TSA agents have
been caught trying to steal stuff then
there have been people caught trying to
smuggle stuff on the planes
that's real I said that and one night
there was a TSA agent an audience and he
came up to me said hey man I won't let
you know ever since TSA has been
implemented playing some get hijacked
anymore so what do you got to say about
that
I was like yeah true but now planes
disappear
I love getting older and probably oldest
person in this show that's kind of cool
see but in LA in LA when you get older
when you get like 30 and above they make
you feel like you're a dinosaur and
you're dying you know I'm saying that's
what they say that's not true I think I
figured it out if you're 29 and above
you've lived a great life you've seen a
lot of great [ __ ] happen yeah I'm saying
I have you thought all the stuff that
you've seen if you're 29 and above this
guy we saw Jordan and Kobe play in their
prime right we were around for Tupac and
big your eyes that we survived two Bush
presidencies do you realize that two of
them dose you get that too
we saw the internet get created right
and now I'm supposed to feel stupid cuz
I'm 22 year old kid figures out snapchat
before I do that's what I'm supposed to
feel bad about I'm supposed to feel dumb
I never know what the hell they're doing
is it a video or a picture later like
you know kill come give a snap I'm like
yo shout out we hear BuzzFeed is going
down baby they were like dude we're
taking a picture man
I mean you should have said something in
I don't know what you expected for me
yeah you ever realized how protective we
are of our phones like we're too
attached to our phones right I think we
can all agree that right like we could
hear a phone drop right now remember
like oh my god is it okay that's not
like the screen shattered oh my god oh
it was just a droid okay okay nobody
cares nobody cares we hear a baby drop
and every crack were like knows a dumb
baby someone should have held that baby
I don't know why anyone would think that
like you know when you go to you go to
try and like show someone in your phone
you give them their phone and there's
that knee-jerk reaction and snatch it
back it like don't don't touch just okay
just know just look a little bit please
okay no okay here you go no seriously
look right okay look at this picture
look at this picture like this picture
you give him the phone they've earned
your trust you give him their phone and
he starts swiping like what the [ __ ] are
you doing dude I'll break your [ __ ]
finger you [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] tinder
Dawg don't swipe what do you don't just
look just look at your [ __ ] eyes man
it's all you got do you had one job
[ __ ] don't swipe do you guys
store numbers in your phone immediately
when you get it I don't I'm like I have
to text you for three weeks right I had
to text you for three weeks like daily
remember like you know what I think the
Spurs are gonna be in my life for a
little bit now when I was there I think
I'm keeping this version here good job
Quincy great I'm seeing you randomly on
this tree I know - you are on fire right
now we should probably do lunch how do
you feel about that I would love to have
lunch with that man stop it yes
seriously yeah Oh what what Oh what what
what did you rip something would have
just what Dawg Wed Wed Wed what I'm
throwing a party okay okay at the crib
right I need you to come man this Friday
no I gotta calm dog you got it
are you serious you ain't gotta tell me
twice really hair stop it I want what I
lie to you we got my information tell ya
I'll text you right now man got my
number I will send you the details right
now if it's the same number I say maybe
sometime we could do dinner or something
yeah ma'am down
yeah that's great what would you like to
eat I literally eat everything okay all
right
whatever you want salad a salad is great
greenery amen this weekend
Memorial Day bash at my crib BYOB but be
can and will be provided who the [ __ ] is
really dog Wow
[Music]
nah bro I lost my content I had you man
they got a library I'm in there so you
admit it but what you didn't have my
number say hello well I told you I lost
my contact
[Music]
save my number though already saved
screenshot it to okay
like if it's really saved just send me a
screenshot so I can oh you know you
sound like a crazy girlfriend don't have
[Music]
but send me the screenshot though trying
to save your numbers [ __ ]
[Music]
not all men cheat but all men struggle
with cheating see women know how to be
faithful because they've been turning
down dick their whole life whole life
all it is is like friend zone friend
zone I'll [ __ ] you you're my boyfriend I
hate you help me move pick me up from
the airport
that's what that's what it is that
that's that's what it is sight so it's
like so you guys want to be faithful
right let me know I'll be faithful I
could barely turn down Costco samples
you realize yet there's no way in God's
earth I could ever turn down sex okay I
got a few more that might get on out of
here I think they're good but you guys
may not like him but we'll try we'll see
what's that did you plug it yes she's
like I don't want to hear anything bad I
only want happy jokes like tsa tell a
lot about a person by their tattoos you
know I have a lot of tattoos I have
thirty five tattoos and I know um and uh
I have thirty five tattoos and I could
tell a lot about a person by their
tattoos right like for example someone
is like a Bible verse or prayer hands
tattooed on them I know for a fact
they've been to prison you know I'm
saying like I think that's too safe
that's a safe assumption I think we're
all in the pocket with that one right
right or something like looks Hispanic
or has an Asian last name in a koi fish
tattoo their Filipino right we can all
agree right all right if you don't know
what a Filipino is your races all right
we can all agree and I want okay see I
figured out why we go to war you know
America has been in war for like 93
percent of its existence right I think
we're around for like 300 years we've
been in war for like 290 of them or
something like that right that's crazy
right
no why we go to war the [ __ ] that's
why we go to work go to war for two
women that's why we've been in the
Middle East for so long that's why up to
seven okay alright someone I let me I
mean I'm gonna try and deliver
again from the top guys I know why we
guys I know why we go to war right know
why we go to war
cuz oppress the saddest well the go to
war because the presidents have a thing
for women of that country right that's
why we've been in the Middle East for so
long right Bush had a thing for Middle
Eastern women right there was no oil
there's no weapons of mass destruction
have you seen Muslim porn yeah that's
why we're there that's the catch
I'm shooting ninety percent from the
field I'd do one joke where I fly too
close to the Sun you guys get sensitive
okay okay
all right that's a great joke nobody was
harmed into making that joke I'm not
Muslim okay what are you talking about
I'm actually Christian but what does it
have to do with me asking do you want
fish or pork well are you asking me that
because you thought I was Muslim no I
was asking that because that's what the
minis broken down as and I wanted fish
so I asked if you wanted Oh
oh my god it's okay everyone make sure
we're in the same page here yeah I'm
just like really on edge yeah what
happened tell anybody
earlier on the train somebody basically
thought it would be like a funny joke to
say that I had a bomb you're kidding me
right
I couldn't believe it it was so rude and
a very like old-school insult it was
just so offensive because it was so
juvenile it was juvenile it wasn't funny
it was rude it had no originality tons
of things definitely around there yeah
well I mean you could at least made it
clever you know
I mean if he had been clever I feel like
it would have made it a little more
digestible you know no it's still
offensive I still would have been mad I
feel like if the Richard Pryor to Train
it said that you brought her left Oh No
okay let me explain Richard Pryor
specialize in racial humor so if Richard
Pryor himself had came back from the
dead had been in that train or the
Richard Pryor of that train had been on
there I really feel like 99% you would
have left unbelievable
when the mother told me never to date a
black comic I thought it was funny
guys like rap music I love rap music and
when I was some older and so when I was
growing up
rap music inspired you it motivated you
to do [ __ ] you know I'm selling because
I grew up with big E's juicy on the
radio I grew up with Tupac's keep your
head up on the radio you know I'm saying
I grew up with DMX okay it was a tough
sophomore year but you get the gist like
I grew up with you make good songs you
made and now rap music is just verbally
abusive you know I'm saying just a bunch
of mean-spirited rappers talking [ __ ] to
me you know like I was in Hoover on the
way over here I'm just bragging now and
I was in a Hoover on the way over here
and then like just the beat stops and
the last lyrics are yeah you a [ __ ] if
you don't have $100,000 in your bank
account I was like that is it I'm gonna
be here I'm good I'm working two jobs
and I'd appreciate it if he appreciated
my work ethic a little moment
furthermore who keeps a hundred thousand
dollars in your bank account that's
financially irresponsible we all know
that get a CD or IRA everybody knows
that so much smarter [ __ ] you member
then rappers always talking about that I
could take my [ __ ] all the time they're
like haha
don't bring a [ __ ] to buzzfeed I'll
take your [ __ ] ha ha ha ha ha ha please
don't please don't take my [ __ ] I love
her
and we've been together three months
three years to East and one of those
years is a long distance you got your
own money why don't you get your own
[ __ ] kind of mean-spirited take someone
else's [ __ ] without permission right
[ __ ] you wrapper
[Music]
hi it's just someone I said hi who said
hi back
and I I thought it was goin see I am not
excused nice to meet you too what I said
can I buy those guys do you think any
other genre music does this [ __ ] to her
fans though huh I think Blake something
talks at this fanbase like that yeah you
a [ __ ] if you don't have an f250 pickup
truck whoa black you need to calm down
buddy calm down you're about to lose
some of that voice money you keep
talking like that all right well I was
great in EM Zane I just have to say like
if you didn't like that their president
wardrobe then Google some [ __ ] cuz the
world's crazy okay thank you that good I
gonna hang you
[Applause]
[Music]